This is the Lee Detective Agency.
We'll
take on any request.If necessary, we'll carry out undercover investigations.We'll
arbitrate disputes.There's
nothing in the paper that we can't solve
.  It's a police
job, so you
're not in a detective drama swimsuit
[Music]
[Music] What
do you think?
You should put it by your workbench It's art-
like, isn't it? How about a present from me?
No, only quiet people can go over there.
Since when did you start walking
with children? I'm a child, so I'm talking about adults.
It's information about the cat world and sake
. The
problem that puts us all in danger comes first than the cat
.  Music]
Some things are getting more and more unmanageable these days I don't
know where they came from They are
stray cats I
've never heard of such a group before But
that's my
husband The
cat world is
energetic in a suitable era  I used to be a target, but
I disappeared a long time ago. Now I
secretly trade in drugs, and
there are some things I can't tell people.
[Music]
[Laughter]
That instrument It'll be fine next time we meet
Don't overdo it next time
Adults  Yeah
Why do we have to talk about business while drinking
[music] All right
[music]
hangover
happy birthday
[music]
forget ta
[applause]